Liebe Urenkel im Jahre 2050 ich muss
mich jetzt schon bei euch entschuldigen
2023 war wohl das wärmste Jahr seit
125 000 Jahren ja wir wissen jetzt schon
wie schlimm es ist mit dem Klimawandel
aber es ist uns scheißegal ja sorry
andere Dinge waren wichtiger Wohlstand
Wachstum
zilinder 2015 haben wir in Paris das
1,5° Ziel beschlossen und wir können es
uns jetzt schon dahin schieben wo zu
viel Sonne scheint es werden wohl eher
so drei bis 4° kleiner Witz am Rande
gerade findet wieder die UN
Klimakonferenz statt in du glaubst es
nicht in
Dubai gar nicht lustig wir haben es
verkackt warte mal l wen schreie ich
hier eigentlich an ach ja mich selbst
ich Idiot